[Music]
shut down has become one of total
insanity in my opinion open the city
open Clark County open the state for
heaven's sakes for being closed is
killing us already so those are just
some of the comments that Las Vegas
mayor Carolyn Goodman made during a City
Council meeting on Wednesday and now she
is doubling down on her push to bring
the city's business back to life I had a
chance to sit down with her in her
office at City Hall yesterday morning
and here's a portion of that interview
would they agree with the idea of
reopening businesses it's not my call to
make no but you're the mayor you
wouldn't make that call unless you had
hopefully some acknowledgement that it's
a healthy idea to reopen businesses in
the city it is what we do we do when I
respond I'm responding to the
constituent let's see we have probably
every day hundreds I can't even begin to
tell you numbers of people do something
give us our jobs back we can't shop we
don't have money to buy food for our
families
we can't pay gas we don't have
transportation we're gonna be destitute
as there was no pre-planning and we shut
down there originally planning for an
unprecedented pandemic we've never done
it before in the history of the United
States we've never shut down one state
anywhere
we have never shut down the entire
country but you don't think the data is
accurate you think these numbers are it
doesn't matter what I think what I was
talking about the data as being the
basis for why you should reopen it so
you say the data is useful to reopen
business but the data isn't useful for
determining who has died or who is it
come down no it's just part of the facts
of how it's reported it's information we
all need clear information but nobody
really has the accuracy to know what is
fact and unless you're there and you're
part of the action which of course none
of
sar but i am in close contact with the
head of UMC and very involved in talking
to people but the most important thing
is as you close down the economy of the
state there's nothing left here just
another portion of our interview with
Mayor Goodman yesterday if you want to
watch the entire interview you can go to
eight News now.com and you can see it in
its entirety